rêver chercher l'inconnu chercher
ce qui est beau est sa propre récompense
la portée d'un homme devrait dépasser sa portée ou
quel est le paradis
tu es l'explorateur dans ta main
je devais trouver le perdu ce que tu cherches est
bien plus grand quand tu l'as jamais imaginé  c'est
ton truc de ne pas te connaître quand tu reviens
Je sais que c'est un sacrifice pour nous tous
les environnements construits un
voyage difficile peut bien signifier ta vie mais tu
pourrais récupérer ton nom de famille
personne ne revient de là-haut
mais nous '  Je n'ai jamais laissé la peur déterminer notre
avenir que vous espérez réaliser ici
si nous pouvions trouver la civilisation cachée et
bien une était considérée comme impossible à
exister nous pourrions bien écrire un tout nouveau
chapitre de l'histoire je l'appelle la mort est la
mort
vous